[Applauso]
il software a due cose estremamente
interessanti da un lato ci permette di
risolvere un problema in svariati modi e
la soluzione migliore è quella perfetta
per quella singola applicazione potrà
essere scritta da persone diverse in
modi diversi con linguaggi diversi e si
tratta sempre di risolvere il piccolo
enigma e trovare il modo più efficiente
il secondo elemento estremamente
interessante è che il software determina
la nostra libertà di azione
se ci pensate quanti strumenti c'erano
sulla vostra scrivania e oggi non ci
sono più sono stati dematerializzati
sono entrati nel vostro computer adesso
nel vostro smartphone
quanti strumenti nuovi abbiamo ecco così
il diritto il primo giorno a
giurisprudenza
tutti gli studenti iniziano quasi sempre
con una frase che suona più o meno così
il diritto è ovunque
da quando vi alzate al mattino accendete
la luce
prendete l'autobus andate in università
o andate a lavoro pagate il pranzo
tornate a casa vi mettete a dormire
pagate l'affitto tutto è regolato da un
contratto anche quando non ce ne
rendiamo conto
ecco è questa comunanza e questa
permeabilità del diritto della
tecnologia che li rende in realtà le
chiavi per capire che cosa possiamo e
che cosa non possiamo fare ma non solo
diritto e tecnologia sono uniti dal
codice il codice in un certo senso la
chiave è appunto il codice che creiamo
per comunicare cose molto complesse in
modo semplice
o almeno questo dovrebbe essere ogni
materia ogni singolo ambito
professionale crea il proprio strumento
per comunicare all'interno del proprio
ambito e per semplificare quello che
altrimenti sarebbe quasi incomunicabile
pensiamo al linguaggio il linguaggio è
il codice per eccellenza quello che
utilizziamo tutti che impariamo fin da
bambini
sono tante lingue nel mondo difficile
che uno strumento di linguaggio diventi
universale che possa comprendere davvero
tutta la complessità della cultura di
varie nazioni
allo stesso modo altri codici si sono
via via susseguiti nella codificazione
appunto delle nostre conoscenze quello
che si ha però creato e che in un certo
senso dietro questi codici ci siamo
nascosti ci siamo barricati li abbiamo
resi difficili forse a volte troppo
difficili forse a volte incomunicabili
ma quello che è importante anche nel
linguaggio e la traduzione
la traduzione è imparare l'inglese oggi
come oggi l'imparare la capacità di
parlare con persone diverse e allo
stesso modo
quello di cui mi occupo e cercare di
tradurre la lingua dell'innovazione
della tecnologia nella lingua del
diritto lingua del diritto che non può
fare a meno di parlare con la lingua
dell'innovazione questo perché il
diritto e la tecnologia si trovano via
via a interfacciarsi in molte molte
volte sia l'uno impattando l'altro
quindi il diritto determinando come la
tecnologia deve agire sia da tecnologia
e l'innovazione dando degli input forti
al diritto pensiamo negli ultimi anni
quante nuove problematiche quante nuove
possibilità abbiamo e quindi quante
nuove regole sociali esistono
ecco proviamo a pensare a come il
diritto dovrebbe essere qualcosa che
permette a tutti di comprendere le
regole sociali che comprende tutti gli
permettere che cosa possono e non
possono fare e quanto invece sia
difficile per farlo proviamo reperire un
reperto della nostra cultura italiana il
i promessi sposi nei promessi sposi
l'azzeccagarbugli cerca di spiegare
arena a renzo che cosa dice il diritto
rispetto alle sue possibilità di sposare
lucia e anche quando loro si recano
dalla quando renzi luce si recano da don
abbondio
egli non perché non possiamo sposarci la
risposta è parlare in latino parlare una
lingua difficile parlare con la lingua
del diritto che chiudeva
perché aprire e tutt'oggi un po e così
con la tecnologia
quello che possiamo fare è avere più e
più possibilità di comunicare
utilizzarla come un abilitatore per
tradurre lingue diverse è essa stessa
però una lingua quindi in tutta questa
complessità
dobbiamo cercare appunto di trovare un
codice nuovo un modo nuovo semplice di
parlare tra tutte le tecnologie che
impattano la il diritto quella una delle
più interessanti di cui vorrei parlare
oggi è l'intelligenza artificiale
l'intelligenza artificiale è quella
branca della informatica che studia come
simulare l'intelligenza umana
all'interno di una macchina
questo può essere fatto in diversi modi
o attraverso la robotica quindi macchine
che eseguono ripetitivamente lo stesso
lo stesso tas che lo stesso compito più
e più volte
oppure può essere fatto attraverso il
cognitive computing il cognitive
computing è quella scienza che studia
come simulare l'intelletto cioè la
capacità di compiere una decisione come
questo impatta sul diritto il diritto è
in realtà la regola secondo la quale
dovremo prendere una decisione e quindi
questo è senz'altro via via più
interessante ma alcuni di voi potrebbero
dirmi ma di intelligenza artificiale di
cognitive computing non abbiamo iniziato
a parlare oggi abbiamo iniziato a
parlare in campo scientifico
già anni fa perché interessante oggi è
interessante oggi per due motivi da un
lato perché con l'aumento della
diffusione della tecnologia
abbiamo iniziato a diffondere
informazioni abbiamo iniziato a
dematerializzare a codificare a portare
online conoscenza che quindi oggi è via
via più utile e più accessibile e
attraverso questa si sono sviluppati
moltissimi algoritmi chiamati di natural
language processing o per dirla
all'italiana processamento del
linguaggio naturale quindi come una
macchina può tradurre la lingua umana
all'interno di input che la macchina
comprende per avere una macchina che è
in grado di capire la macchina stessa
che deve tradurre nel suo proprio
linguaggio
determinata una determinata informazione
ma non solo
non è solo per questo motivo che
l'intelligenza artificiale è
estremamente interessante perché
attraverso questo sistema noi abbiamo la
possibilità insomma di dire alla
macchina di far capire alla macchina
alle leggi e poi di farcele restituire
in qualche altro formato immaginiamo che
una persona che non sa niente di
giurisprudenza possa scrivere e
richiedere un informazione attraverso un
motore di ricerca e ottenere la risposta
che stava cercando
sarebbe meraviglioso
non solo però oggi come oggi ci sono via
via più strumenti che si trovano ad
essere attori veri e propri del diritto
pensiamo alle macchina guida autonoma è
un futuro lontano ma non lontanissimo
in questo futuro oggi al presente il
codice della strada
lo scriviamo in linguaggio naturale alla
macchina alla guida c'è un uomo che
quindi pensa conosce e agisce cosa
succede se domani a pensare alla
macchina se domani a pensare la macchina
a quelle stesse norme dovranno essere
tradotte e tradotte in un linguaggio che
la macchina comprende lei stessa non
soltanto che noi come esseri umani
comprendiamo e quindi in questo caso
sarà via via più necessario avere anche
persone che sanno comunicare con le
macchine perché questo sarà importante
perché sarà importante poter controllare
che cosa una macchina compie non
soltanto a livello di tusk ma anche a
livello della sua possibilità di azione
e quindi sarà sempre più importante che
ci siano persone esperte delle
problematiche del mondo come sono i
giuristi e persone esperte di come
funzionano le macchine che siano in
grado di comunicare tra di loro quindi
l'intelligenza artificiale diventa uno
degli strumenti e uno degli impatti
fondamentali nel mondo del diritto per
le due ragioni che vi ho spiegato quindi
da una parte perché può rendere più
facile l'accesso agli stessi esseri
umani e sono arrivati a comprendere una
complessità tale dei loro rapporti e
delle loro relazioni per cui hanno
paradossalmente bisogno quasi di una
macchina perché gli spieghi come
veramente stanno funzionando quelle
relazioni
dall'altra perché via via più strumenti
saranno connessi alla rete e quegli
strumenti dovranno rispettare le stesse
regole che rispettiamo noi o forse
regole diverse
insomma all'interno di questo dialogo è
sempre più importante essere persone un
po fatte atti cioè essere persone che
sono capaci di avere una competenza che
si dice trasversale conoscere molto bene
un settore e conoscere abbastanza degli
altri settori così da poter espandere la
propria conoscenza non soltanto
rimanendo fissati alla proprio ma
espandendola creando relazioni con altre
persone creando relazioni con altri
settori
e questo è via via più importante e
questo è un po quello che è quello che
cerco di fare attraverso una tecnologia
nuova non nuovissima come tutte le
tecnologie vivono una fase di
incubazione molto lunga per cui ogni
volta che si definisce una tecnologia
nuova e difficile definirla tale perché
ci sono stati anni anni di studio prima
che arrivi sulla diciamo sulla bocca di
tutti ma quest'anno senz'altro tutti
avrete sentito parlare di block chaining
non tutti avremo ovviamente capito che
cos'è
anche perché gli stessi addetti del
settore ancora un po discutono
effettivamente su quale sia il confine
di questa parola essenzialmente pro
block chain è un protocollo di
comunicazione che al contrario del
nostro internet di oggi che mantiene le
informazioni in un server e le comunica
agli dispositivi connessi alla rete
roxanne invece è la capacità di un di
una rete di avere le informazioni su
tutti i dispositivi collegati che si
condividono e si comunicano tra di loro
e ogni volta che c'è un'informazione
nuova sulla rete questa viene aggiornata
su ogni singolo dispositivo
perché tutto questo perché è rilegato
con diritto perché in realtà questo ci
permetterebbe di avere il diritto
scritto e codificato in un modo per cui
non può essere modificato per cui in
realtà il patto sociale che noi
riteniamo di firmare con uno stato con
la società in cui viviamo è codificato
immutabile possiamo controllarlo non c'è
un hacker che può andare a modificare
quello che c'è scritto in un testo un po
come facciamo con la carta scriviamo
sulla carta copiativa e diamo per
scontato che nessuno scriva al contrario
di quello che diremmo noi ecco questo è
esattamente quello che fa blocking
quindi permetterebbe di comunicare tra
macchine connesse alla rete e allo
stesso tempo questo per il sistema
centralizzato e decentralizzato che vi
dicevo prima permetterebbe la
coordinazione tra di loro e che quindi
se è impossibile rovinando una sola
macchina e quindi magari dando
un'informazione diversa modificare
quello che pensano tutte le altre
macchine e quindi creare quella rete di
connessione che oggi ancora nei sistemi
informatici un po manca e quindi è la
scoperta e la scoperta di unire cose
diverse la scoperta di essere una
persona appassionata di tecnologia come
ne conosco che dalla programmazione sono
passati alla genetica in grado di
comprendere la complessità del codice
anche a capire la complessità del dna e
a unire queste cose creando un grande
valore
le più grandi scoperte vengono da side
effects cose che non ci aspettavamo e
che poi proprio perché non ce
l'aspettavamo magari diventano via via
più importanti quindi mio taker di oggi
è abbattiamolo questo muro non possiamo
più permetterci di confinare la
conoscenza all'interno delle nostre
piccole scatole
prendiamoci del tempo per aprire quella
porta e andare a vedere cosa c'è
dall'altra parte e non è lontano è in
questa sala è in ognuno di voi poggi che
fa una cosa è che a un expertise in un
area ma imparando a comunicarlo ad altri
potrà partecipare al grand grande
dialogo globale sull'innovazione
grazie
[Applauso]